[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy glorious wednesday everyone what a
wednesday it is or was because it's late
so earlier this week people really
freaked out about china launching that
nuclear-capable hypersonic missile
it's an advance in weaponry that
surprised us officials i know who knew
that china would launch something
harmful
that ends up going around the world
probably should have been prepared for
that
apparently the long march rocket ended
up missing its target by only 24 miles
but it's just like getting up in the
middle of the night to pee
it's close enough to matter
but look i think we're focusing on the
wrong stuff china may have just launched
a hypersonic weapon but we're killing
them in so many other areas like for
example they only have two pronouns
we have 237
and and and despite launching a rocket
yeah they have no diversity programs
have you ever seen a picture of all of
their astronauts
they're all
they're all
chinese dare you clap for that racism
meanwhile we're really good at building
non-binary bathrooms complete with
private changing rooms in case you feel
like hitting the battlefield looking fun
and flirty
we may lose the war but we'll all be
buried in versace's fall collection
true china's schools are so good they
turn out many of our top stem college
grads but our schools are better because
we've learned teaching math is racist
they're colonizing their neighboring
countries but we are decolonizing
science right
i don't know what that means
but don't get depressed while china is
busy trying to destroy us
we are too you think china's got an edge
on america you haven't seen how america
is doing against america we are killing
it literally yeah we are kicking our own
ass
and we don't need your help chyna we
already beat you to it we have a black
belt in self-destruction
take this barely reported story it's a
big story according to the new york post
a fire that was started by a sailor
slash arsonist that destroyed the
massive navy ship the uss upon home
richard don't correct me
the ship last year was allowed to burn
for days due to both individual and
systemic failures it was due to a crew
that was quote inadequately prepared to
battle the blaze yeah inadequately
prepared you know if only there was some
water nearby to put out the fire
a report finds that there were
widespread lapses in training
coordination communication fired
preparedness equipment maintenance and
overall command and control but other
than that everything ran great
of course how important really are those
variables as long as you denounced white
rage when communicating with the
firefighters after all those long hoses
represent the patriarchy that's been
oppressing women for centuries
so the navy had to scrap the ship
because it would have taken seven years
and three billion dollars to fix it
of course trump weighed in and said he
could do it in 10 months for under 10
grand
if they agreed to rename the ship
it's almost believable somehow fixing
this ship doesn't qualify as
infrastructure but free education for
illegals does
so we can't put out a fire but we did
read up on anti-racism and white
supremacy we can't fight fires but we
can fire military academy members simply
because they were appointed by trump
today it seems that woke-ism is the only
thing that's flame retardant well that
in biden's spider-man pajamas
but it shows how we are beating china at
beating ourselves i wonder what the
angry white male has to say
[Music]
you know the way china's been acting
lately embarrassing us on the world
stage acting aggressively in the south
china sea and then there's the virus i
call it the china virus but i guess
you're not supposed to do that
i keep thinking the united states is
gonna do something about it but we keep
trading with them and acting as if
nothing's wrong i guess it's because
we're nice yeah that's it we're nice
[Applause]
that is
that hypersonic weapon only exposed the
folly of our priorities we are no longer
competing with china as a superpower we
are dismantling the superpower that we
once were for every new standard their
weapon set we lower a standard in our
schools we are our very own enemy now
and we don't even have to lift a weapon
we are the weapon
because when our military and
intelligence sees the typical american
as a threat china already won of course
we never made it hard for them that
country has the advantage of not having
an academic media and entertainment
establishment that works overtime to
subvert their security but that i guess
that's part of america being a free
country
but why be so maliciously stupid about
it just because we can destroy ourselves
why should we destroy ourselves that's
something my primary care physician
asked me every time he sees me shirtless
china also does not produce social
justice warriors whereas we've become
the world's assembly line of these
fascist cretins a nuclear weapon can
destroy a city but just one woke warrior
could destroy everything without
blowback radiation no wonder china
embraces woke american companies china
gets paid by america while propping up a
pernicious ideology that permanently
craps all over america it's like paying
a hit man to shoot yourself
our companies embrace black lives matter
here while embracing slave labor there
and like the women's soccer team in
tokyo america loses
like to rub it in because we ignore
we ignore the bigger uglier problem
while obsessing over problems that don't
exist
hey bob what's up
uh
i think there's something wrong with
this foot i don't know what about that
foot
this one
maybe a pedicure
yes
so
as china reaches for the stars and i
don't mean lebron james or john cena
we reach for the anti-racist policy
manual it's sad china gave us both covid
and stockholm syndrome perhaps we should
be quaking in our boots but they're
probably made in china anyway
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests
she's been in more hot spots than aloe
vera journalist and host of the laura
logan has no agenda on fox station laura
logan
he's exposed more democrats than jeffrey
epstein's flight log fox's contributor
and washington times opinion editor
charlie hurts so good
when he's headlining the venue maximum
occupancy is not an issue
comedian joe
becky
the only time she remains silent is
after hearing her miranda rights fox's
contributor
that's him
laura welcome to the show thank you so
happy to finally we just met yeah what
took you so long i don't know
i was scared of you intimidated might be
the best word are you do you think that
chyna is thrilled that america has gone
so woke
yes i mean without a doubt if you go
back to 1999 two chinese colonels wrote
a book on asymmetric warfare and that's
what you're seeing being implemented
their strategy they've updated it since
it covers everything from taking you
know all of our manufacturing capability
from us which was exposed you know with
the pandemic hit we realized oh well we
without china we got no antibiotics
right got no medical equipment so what
did they do to change that
nothing right and when china got all
that capability that's how they found
the analogs for fentanyl which they then
introduced as a street drug made a deal
with the mexican cartels and now they've
got what how many americans are dying
yes every year and we hear nothing about
it yeah and what happens when you're you
know with when you're doing drugs you're
not paying taxes you're not joining the
military you're not holding down a job i
mean this is what asymmetric warfare is
about is dismantling your society from
within and for some reason politicians
today i mean go to san francisco nobody
cares that you got people standing on
the street pissing on themselves and you
know and defecating everywhere you know
and uh unable to function and what do
they say well let's reduce the mandatory
minimum sentencing for fentanyl that's
what the bible administration justice
department is working on right now so we
don't talk about any of those things and
uh and so and how the defense department
can say it didn't see this coming the
nsa is the crown jewel of intelligence
collection for the world i mean they've
been missing a lot of stuff they have
they have but they've been focusing on
the pronouns and i think that's
important laura how dare you just
overlook the pronouns by the way i have
to point uh poke a hole in your theory
cat does drugs and she still has a job
here's a job
right charlie i'm so glad you wore your
christmas socks well i did it for you
yes exactly i i i i was out of my argyle
socks yes yours are great so it seems to
me that our social justice warriors are
replacing our real warriors uh do you
find that statement to be the case or do
you have something smarter to say no i
don't uh as you know i don't um
yeah no it's amazing and uh and and
obviously the worst is the the political
set in washington um who are supposed to
be in charge of of not letting this sort
of thing happen and looking out for
america's interests and it is kind of
amazing when a guy like donald trump
comes along and of course everybody gets
so upset about all the stuff that he
says and the way he says it all but at
the end of the day the thing that really
upset people in washington was that his
political mantra was america first right
and everything that that he did uh you
know every uh platform of his that got
him elected was designed to
wrench uh power away from washington
like dealing with the border deal and of
course and let's also not forget that
america's not lost and just look at the
border when you look at these tens of
thousands of people who are who still
believe america is the place that they
want to be and they're dying literally
risking their lives to come here
hundreds of thousands yeah and and
they're coming here because they still
believe america is what it is but but
it's like but but you're right we we we
have discovered the enemy and it is us
yes and and uh although i don't think
it's the the regular amer i mean people
are still signing up to fight yeah the
true warriors are still signing up to
fight and and that's the reminder of why
we don't have a choice none of us here
has a choice to sort of give up and walk
away because we still have people
signing up to literally fight for our
country and we have to do it too thank
god for that all right uh joe were you
terrified when you saw that hypersonic
missile i was terrified greg but i've
been terrified for a long time about a
great many things
our relationship with china reminds me
of when i'm walking up the stairs at uh
to our office and there'll be a
co-worker and i'll sometimes start
running and say last one up is a loser
and and they'll be like i didn't know we
were competing
it's the only way i can beat cat yeah
but it's like we've got all these
symbols that we're in a competition and
we're just ignoring it like we gave
china most favored nation trade status
and what do they do they start dumping
their products we invite them into the
wto what do they do they start
manipulating their currency they take
over hong kong and we're like freedom
sucks
[Laughter]
that is true
kat is china just simply waiting us out
like they don't really have to do
anything we can just finish the job you
look at some of this stuff like with
that naval ship i was reading that
article about it and it said well no you
know there was a button that activated
foam but nobody knew the location of the
button
and i'm like there was a button
there think about that how many problems
in the world could be solved with just a
button like not that many no it's true
how right like that training right i
don't have a military background so like
you're married to a veteran i am so
happy
yes of course
um freedom's not free but um
i could have conducted that training yes
here's the button if the ship is on fire
push it boom but
but did that
what if that button i mean does that put
a little post-it note if ship on fire
push this arrow
how do you mess that up it seems harder
to mess that up than to not mess that up
but what if
pushing a button seems somewhat
oppressive
i mean pushing just the act of pushing
it's an act of violence it's racist it
might be even racist yeah you're right a
lot of people were pushed around right
it is much better to allow the ship to
go up in flames exactly exactly
i'm glad you agree with me all right hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else